ça y est de 2,7 on déclare une situation
d'urgence on a notre gouverne de
profondeur qui est bloqué on approche de
cet évier et je vois des gens partout et
quand je vous dirais rentrée les volets
rentrent-ils train d'atterrissage régler
aussi le tri m'a piqué a piqué oui quand
je vous dis est de pousser là dessus
mais t'es plein gaz puissance maxi c'est
d'accord oui mais seulement quand
j'étais ok ce qu'on va faire pourquoi du
trim appliquée nous allons leur tournée
commencé à retourner faut qu'on arrête
ce plongeon margaret comment s'appelle
votre fils dit je t'aime très fort voire
la boîte noire dit je t'aime très fort
en thème très fort qui est un bon fils
mon grand maman paquet c'est parti je
reprends le contrôle jeudi
halluciné pas ce volet wii aérofreins
aérofreins
à
bah gagnera gastou
t